herrschaften ruhe bitte heute möchte ich
über in ihr reden den deutschen
abiturienten wie schafft es eine der
reichsten kulturnationen der welt
aufgeweckte kinder in die höchsten
jugendlichen zu verwandeln
das klingt ganz beleidigend aber er
versteht eh nicht wovon ich rede
das passiert wenn 16 kultusminister in
ihrem stammesgebiet experimente am
offenen kinder hirn vollziehen morgens
g9 mittags dr
nächste woche 3 der größte feind der
bildung ist sich rtl2 oder crack rauchen
es ist der verdammte föderalismus hier
mathebuch für die zwölfte klasse in
bayern analytische geometrie ableitungen
und funktionen gleichzeitig lernen die
zwölfte klasse in berlin mit kevin hat
häufig zu rechnen mit einer hand wer
dann auch im leistungskurs geschichte in
diese frage beantworten kann
wie hieß karl der große mit vornamen
karl stefan oder plastik mit den reich
zum studiengang deutsche anders begabte
noch ein schießtraining oben drauf und
man kann lehrer werden in duisburg
dieselbe industrie die jahrelang das
turbo-abi gefordert hat sagt jetzt diese
kinder können ja gar nicht ich habe wie
denn auch
gerade mal drei jahren mazedonische
tanztheater auf bachelor in wuppertal
dass die armen plagen doch einfach mal
in ruhe mit euren reformen
wir haben doch alle schon mit 9 den
ersten burnout humana wäre sie kurz nach
der geburt im wald auszusetzen
dann werden sie von füchsen und wölfen
aufgezogen und dann wahrscheinlich mehr
du wirst ausgewählt hat erlaubte befreit
politiker mappus weg mappus
[Applaus]